also es gibt zwei antworten auf diese
frage nämlich zum einen wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir keine modernen
animismus anheimfallen das heißt dass
wir software systemen die so designt
sind dass sie bestimmte menschliche
fähigkeiten simulieren dann mit mentalen
kognitiven und anderen eigenschaften
ausstatten
die diese nicht haben das ist eine
moderne form des animismus die der
erstaunlicherweise sehr weit verbreitet
ist und das zweite ist es gibt ein
wichtiges resultat das ist das
wichtigste logische und meta meta
mathematische theorien überhaupt nämlich
das von kurt gödel und dieses zeigt in
meinen augen zwingend dass die fähigkeit
menschlicher deliberation die uns zb
ermöglicht dass wir theoreme der
prädikaten logik erster stufe beweisen
obwohl bewiesen ist durch gödel dass es
keine algorithmische form der
beweisführung gibt das ist eine
ultimative grenze und möglicherweise hat
das eine tiefendimension das nämlich
kreativität intuition das neue zu
entdecken hängt vermutlich mit diesem
nicht algorithmischen charakter
menschlichen denkens zusammen
es ist eine ganz schwierige frage weil
bislang so gut wie alle prognosen die
mit neuen technologien und speziell mit
digitalen technologien einher gegangen
sind sich als falsch herausgestellt
haben das papierlose büro hat es bisher
nicht gegeben im gegenteil es wird mehr
papier produziert als früher
die überflüssigkeit von stetten weil man
sich ja nicht ein begegnet begegnen muss
hat sich auch nicht als zutreffend
herausgestellt meetings bestimmen das
berufliche alltag leben so mehr als
früher
auch das eigentlich streng genommen
überflüssig das heißt ich bin vorsichtig
mit prognosen ich will aber sagen wenn
man in die geschichte der
digitalisierung schaut das ist ja
immerhin auch nicht mehr seit gestern
das ist ja schon seit beginn der 90er
jahre in der form wie wir es jetzt
kennen hat sie zum
produktivitätswachstum einen gewissen
beitrag in den 90er jahren geleistet
aber gerade jetzt in dieser phase der
sehr starken digitalisierung seit mitte
der nullerjahre sinkt die produktivität
ab auf einen historischen tiefstand von
0,4 bis 0,5 prozent in den usa
das lässt nicht erwarten dass wir in
naher zukunft per saldo sehr viele
arbeitsplätze verlieren werden das ist
ja eine der großen sorgen wir müssen uns
keine gedanken bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen machen aber wir müssen
uns darauf einstellen dass es ganz neue
herausforderungen in der arbeitswelt und
in der bildung gibt nämlich menschen mit
digitalen kompetenzen zu versehen die
sie fit machen für diese neue
arbeitswelt
also die robotik
meinen augen eine fehlentwicklung
genommen nämlich möglichst humanoide
roboter zu entwickeln wie sie auch zum
beispiel in der pflege zum einsatz
kommen ich will das nicht grundsätzlich
ablehnen das kann sinnvoll sein das ist
auch ein beitrag zur menschenwürde unter
umständen nicht jeder möchte von einem
doch weitgehend fremden menschen auf die
toilette getragen werden das ist viel
angenehmer wenn das einkommen ein
roboter leistet aber dass humanoide ist
problematisch weil es nämlich diese
fehlinterpretation wir hätten hier ein
gegenüber das mit uns kommuniziert und
interagiert dass unsere einsamkeit
vielleicht mildert diese viel
interpretation wird dadurch gefördert
das ist der entscheidende cut den wir
machen sollten keine mystifizierung und
dann gibt es in der tat
herausforderungen nämlich vor allem im
bereich der kommunikation die
kommunikationsstrukturen ändern sich
durch die digitalen technologien und
dazu gehört auch dass die menschen
zunehmend auch algorithmen gesteuert in
filter blasen sich bewegen das heißt die
information bekommen die sie vorher
schon mal abgefragt haben
meinungsforscher in diesen blasen und
was dabei verloren gehen kann ist das
gemeinsame was in der demokratie so
wichtig ist nicht nur gruppenbildung
sozusagen ein moderner tribalismus
sondern wir als bürgerinnen bürger
bilden und unsere auffassung die alte
kommunistische bildungsorientierung an
urteilskraft und persönlichkeitsbildung
ist heute so wichtig wie noch nie